las cifras parecen indicar que siempre
hay más gente que sufre de obesidad en
el mundo porque este aumento continuo
bueno las cifras han aumentado han
aumentado en todo el mundo y
especialmente aquí en América Latina yo
creo que en este en este instante se
debe a tres factores yo creo que a la
Pobreza a un aumento de la pobreza a un
momento de la inflación y
el precio de los alimentos saludables y
a un aumento de desigualdad este aumento
de la inflación se ha visto posterior a
el conflicto de Ucrania etcétera
etcétera Y eso ha hecho que casi un
22,5% de la población de América Latina
no tenga acceso a una alimentación
saludable qué responsabilidad tienen los
estados en la lucha contra la obesidad
Precisamente en un contexto en el que
usted menciona que los precios de los
alimentos suben pero la comida chatarra
sigue siendo accesible
yo creo que yo creo que tiene mucha
responsabilidad el estado
en varios aspectos primero en tratar la
obesidad como una enfermedad yo creo que
que Todavía existe este prejuicio por
parte de las
obesidad se debe a una actitud personal
de la del paciente y debe ser tratado
como por el paciente ese esos paradigmas
han cambiado con el tiempo y ya se sabe
que la obesidad tiene existen múltiples
factores que influyen en su
teopatra Eugenia factores que son desde
el punto de vista psicológico
nutricional
celtarismo
la misma alimentación etcétera etcétera
genéticos etcétera se han identificado
más de 140 lupus en que producen
obesidad y esos ser transmitidos de
generación en generación Yo creo que
tiene el Estado mucho que hacer en todas
estas en todas estas áreas
promoviendo en primer lugar Una
alimentación saludable segundo
disminución del sedentarismo tercero
cuando el paciente
tiene que ser tratado
poder poner al Servicio del paciente los
médicos etcétera para que siga un
tratamiento multidisciplinario y pueda
no sé si es que requiere el último caso
realizarse una cirugía realizarse una
cirugía y eso se ha cubierto por el
estado